Marvel Studios did something incredibly
huge today A lot of people are
overlooking the fact that today the MCU
just took a step at becoming bigger than
it's ever been before yes Marvel Studios
and the MCU have had some problems but
just think about everything the MCU has
in store for us that we already know
Deadpool 3 will be insane we already
know Avengers Secret Wars is going to be
epic and then of course the X-Men and
the Fantastic 4 are coming to the MCU
and Marvel Studios today took a big step
in the right direction for the MCU yes
it is the release of the echo series and
yes it is actually a historic day for
Marvel Studios as they have officially
released their first Marvel Studios
Spotlight Banner project but I'm not
talking about either of these really
what we're talking about today is the
official launch of the division of
sections of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the story of the street level
Avengers team begins today with more
different and separate Avengers teams
coming Kevin fagy has teased this for
such a long time and it's finally
happening and it's a lot bigger than
most people realize and although we are
still in the Multiverse Saga at this
point and this news does affect the
Multiverse Saga the next Saga has the
potential to be the best Saga yet and
the biggest Saga yet combining so many
different teams like the X-Men the
Fantastic 4 the Inhumans if Marvel ever
really decides to bring them into the
MCU and multiple different Avengers
teams that are really different from
each other that will consist of
different Avengers characters so let me
explain how the MCU today just got
bigger than it's ever been before and if
you're new be sure to subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date on all things
relating to the MCU and if you subscribe
and leave a comment down below you are
automatically entered in our giveaway
for chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series X
some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items the winner gets to pick one item
and we pick one winner at the end of
each month so yes in the MCU we have had
movies and now shows that are in
different parts of the Marvel Galaxy but
now we're going to get one off Avengers
films the street Avengers The Cosmic
Avengers the West Coast Avengers and
make no mistake like I said they will be
divided teams not divided as in against
each other although there is rumors that
Marvel Studios could potentially be
developing a Civil War II movie right
now and of course I'm sure we'll get an
Avengers vers X-Men film eventually at
least we hope we do but no these
separate Avengers teams will all be kind
of working together they'll just have
different teams doing different things
in different parts of the MCU and the
cool thing is they're each going to have
their own big bad in fact Marvel Studios
has already officially announced one big
bad for one of the Avengers teams he's
already kind of debuted in the MCU and
he officially comes back to the MCU
today we are talking about Kingpin in
fact Marvel Studios went as far to say
as he is pretty much the Thanos of the
street level corner of the MCU this is
what Marvel studios's executive and head
of development for Disney Plus for
Marvel Brad wbom was asked in an
interview with screenrant he was asked
if Kingpin is the Thanos of the street
level corner of the MCU in which he
replied oh man you kind of hit the nail
on the head I can't say too much only
that as a chapter in Wilson fist's life
this is a crucial one and sets the stage
in some remarkable ways for what's
coming next and this really does have so
many different amazing implications to
it this means we are essentially kind of
going to have Avengers films inside of
Avengers films it's kind of going to be
like Avengers Inception and ultimately
the goal for Marvel Studios is to have
everything come together in the end in a
grand Avengers film but let's dial it
back and scale it down for a second
there will be many different corners of
the MCU we've talked about these
different sides a lot we have the street
level Avengers team we have the cosmic
Avengers team we have the supernatural
side and hopefully during The Saga we
get kind of a multiversal side what's
really interesting is that moving
forward each of these different sections
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe will
have their own villains and let me be
very clear this is very different than
what Marvel Studios has done before
before with the past three phases each
movie had their own individual villain
Captain America had Red Skull the Winter
Soldier Hydra Iron Man had Iron Monger
Whiplash Hulk had Abomination and Thor
is kind of the exception because Loki
shows up again as the main villain of
the Avengers film however that's just
phase one and ultimately Thanos doesn't
really appear as the villain in any
movie really yes he appears in Guardians
of the Galaxy but Ronin is the main
villain of that film and no villain is
really dealt with by more than one
person or one group of people for
example Hela nobody really dealt with
Hela besides Thor the Hulk Valkyrie and
Loki really every single villain for
every movie was secluded and kept to one
movie now that's all about to change
with the separate corners of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe each having their own
villains their own big bads the MCU is
about to become a lot more connected
because now these villains of these
sections of the MCU are going to appear
in more than one film in more than one
project because they'll be both in
movies and in Disney Plus shows and
Kingpin really is the perfect example
we've already seen him in two different
projects and not to mention Daredevil as
well Kingpin was introduced in Hawkeye
he is now the villain of Ekko he'll also
go on to still be one of the main
villains of the Daredevil series and
then he will go on to be a Spider-Man
villain we've never really seen this
before the only person we've really seen
this with is Loki but he himself is now
his own main character and isn't exactly
a villain anymore in fact he's kind of
the savior of the Multiverse right now
so Marvel Studios hasn't done this and
it's a great way to really connect
everything even more so than it's ever
been and like I mentioned this also sets
set up for Heroes to be more connected
as well Daredevil has now been in
She-Hulk he is in the Echo series
releasing today and of course he has his
own series showing up and not to mention
he was also in Spider-Man no way home
you can see how the interconnectivity is
actually becoming more than it's ever
been despite really not feeling it that
much throughout phase 4 and Phase 5 but
imagine really seeing a bunch of these
awesome Heroes interact with each other
throughout multiple different projects
movies and shows and not just for the
sake of having cameos but for the actual
sake of the story you see Kingpin is
really going to tie a lot of different
characters together not only is he
appearing in multiple different projects
but he's also going to become the mayor
of New York City and from what we've
heard about what's going to happen in
Daredevil he's going to make a law that
makes it illegal to be a vigilante so a
lot of Heroes have a pretty big reason
to come together to defeat Kingpin
story-wise it's fantastic it essentially
is an Avengers film which it is indeed
going to be this is is going to be an
Avengers film when they come together
however it won't consist of everything
and everyone that is happening in all of
these different parts of the MCU this is
the team that is going to be dealing
with Kingpin in New York then we're
probably going to have a team on the
west coast and since there's a West
Coast Avengers team in the comics we're
assuming we'll probably get that in the
MCU as well after all it does make sense
to have two different teams on two
different sides of the country of the
United States of America and I wouldn't
be surprised if an Avengers team gets
placed elsewhere somewhere in the world
or multiple teams placed throughout the
world and it's also important to note
that some of these teams might not be
official Avengers teams like the
midnight Suns the supernatural SL
monster side of the MCU is going to be
huge at least that's what we're all
hoping for with characters like moonight
blade Deadpool Doctor Strange Ghost
Rider the Black Knight Jack Russell Elsa
Bloodstone and more the potential is
insanely big and it said that the big
bad for that side of the MCU the
supernatural side could be Mesto himself
appearing in multiple different projects
because he is going to be intertwined in
all of these character story until they
all eventually come together to defeat
him we know that he's probably going to
be in the Iron Heart series that is
according to deadline they reported that
Sasha baroan is indeed in the project
and is believed to be playing Mesto
based off of their sources then insiders
have come out and stated that his
character should be appearing in other
projects as well so we could be looking
at the big bad of the supernatural side
and he should bring these characters
together not just in one big team up
film but throughout multiple different
projects leading up to that film so you
can see how the MCU could start to
become bigger than it's ever been before
and more connected than it's ever been
before and these are just two sides of
the MCU we know we're also going to have
the story of the X-Men and the story of
the Fantastic Four the X-Men are going
to be really intertwined as well having
individual character stories and team
stories then there's the cosmic side and
there's a lot of story to tell there
with the celestials and Cosmic entities
we have only been briefly introduced to
these huge characters and they play huge
roles in Marvel Comics so you know
they're going to dive further into these
as well and the best part is even though
they're going to be separate corners of
the MCU separate Avengers teams
ultimately at the end there will be a
huge Avengers ingame Avengers Secret
Wars like project that'll bring them all
together and that film has the potential
to really and truly be one of the
biggest films of all time if not the big
film that Marvel Studios could ever
produce so today truly is an epic day so
go ahead and let us know your thoughts
about this in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video And
subscribe to stay up to date on the
latest MCU news you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof